let's talk about the rules of
intermittent fasting i've done
a lot of different videos on this topic
but i just wanted to condense everything
in just one video so let's take it from
the top
a lot of times people want to know what
can i eat with the fast what can i drink
with a fast
let's talk first about drinking water
is fine there's a thing called a dry
fast that's a whole different topic
but i do recommend drinking water
tea is totally fine a certain type of
teas
can help you fast longer and decrease
hunger because the herbs in tea
help support your blood sugars and your
liver
coffee is fine i just wouldn't want to
overdo it but coffee will not
knock you out of ketosis because tea
coffee and water have basically zero
calories
so it's just the amount of calories that
could bump you out of
fasting next question is can i take
certain supplements when i'm fasting
i recommend it especially vitamins
electrolytes minerals b vitamins in the
form of nutritional yeast
trace minerals omega-3 fatty acids
especially dha and so if you're doing
cod liver oil for example or fish oils
the calories are going to be so small
it's going to
not really interfere with your fasting
ideally if you get a green drink
without the fiber let's say a wheatgrass
juice
powder you're getting something that is
super concentrated
usually about 6 to 11 times
less volume of material because it takes
a lot of greens
to make just a little bit of juice from
that and so usually one serving
when you add water comes out to less
than one gram
and so you get the boost of nutrition
without messing up your fasting
what you do want to avoid is the protein
powders especially whey protein
powder and there's many other ones i
would just avoid all protein powders
also avoid branch chain amino acids
because it will turn into sugar pretty
quickly
now as far as bone broth there's mixed
reviews
some people do find that their ketosis
actually stops
for way too long and other people it
doesn't seem to affect their ability to
generate ketones so
this is mixed reviews you might want to
try it out and see if you actually can
do it or not get a little testing unit
to check yourself
now as far as mct oil which sometimes
you're going to put
in your coffee to make it a bulletproof
coffee you can put butter in it you can
just put coconut oil or just put mct oil
what's going to happen is you're not
going to lower your ketones
because those fats will turn into
ketones
but the only thing that's going to
happen if you do too much of this
is you're going to shift from burning
your own fat
to burning this fat and turning it into
ketones
now that's not necessarily a bad thing
especially in the beginning as you're
making the transition into ketosis but
at some point if you find that your
weight loss is stalled
then realize it could be this extra fat
that you're consuming
but i actually do recommend it for a lot
of people
because it allows them to fast longer
which is actually very very important
because you want to get your body
adapting and mct oil can give your brain
straight ketones so
there's some other benefits to taking
mct oil so it's kind of
depends on your situation okay number
three don't
eat unless you're hungry so when you
start this fast
and let's say you're gonna go 18 hours
and your main goal is to lose weight
and you find that you just completely
have
no appetite go a little longer now you
don't have to do
a really long fast right off the
beginning but you're on a roll
your body is eating it's eating its own
fat it's not starving
might as well ride the wave and go a
little bit longer
you're going to see better results but
you want to prevent the point
of going too far where your body is weak
and you feel
dizzy so you want to be able to
differentiate some slight
hunger pains you're a little hungry
but you have a lot of energy and you
have no
cognitive problems might as well just
push through that especially if it's in
the morning at eight o'clock in the
morning where you
have this spike of cortisol where your
body might be releasing more sugar
but most people just push through that
and then the hunger goes away
but you've gone too far if you're very
weak and you're fatigued
and you're dizzy and you have
irritability all right number four
the longer the fast the more you have to
refeed
slowly so if you're fasting for 48 hours
or longer make sure you consume
just a small amount of food maybe a
little egg a little
lettuce maybe a little bit of peanut
butter but not
too much food too fast because what
happens is that
sometimes if you do a long fast
especially if you're getting
like 72 hours or even longer and you
have this huge
meal your system is not ready for it and
you can really feel kind of
bloated nauseous and so i don't
recommend it so just do a little bit of
food wait a little bit have a little bit
more food kind of gradually go into it
number five a good indication to know of
the severity of insulin resistance is
how long can you go
without feeling like you need to eat
food
if you can fast easily over a period of
time
that means that you don't have much
insulin resistance
left there's not a problem now there's
other good indicators too
like if you were to check your blood
sugars and let's say you're fasting your
blood sugars go
up that means that you're not quite out
of the woods
you have insulin resistance because your
body is actually
making more sugar it's called
gluconeogenesis because of certain mixed
messages with insulin connecting to the
liver
and so if you can't fast for a very long
time all that means
is you have insulin resistance and you
have to just keep working on it you have
to give it more time
add more fat to the meal too which will
make you more satisfied and allow you to
go
longer number six i recommend you always
do keto
with intermittent fasting i mean think
about you're getting all these great
benefits with
fasting why wouldn't you also want to
get the benefits from
keto which is also going to keep your
insulin low
when you eat if you're fasting and then
you go to a high carb diet
you're going to raise insulin raise your
blood sugars and kind of
minimize the effects of intermittent
fasting
all right number seven i recommend you
do
periodic prolonged fasting
why because longer fasts give you
additional
benefits there are three really
important benefits that most people get
with
just regular fasting not that long maybe
16 hours
they'll lose weight they'll have
cognitive benefits
memory focus and concentration
and they have mood benefits they go from
anxiety or depression
up to a higher level of emotion they
just feel better
a calm sense of well-being which is huge
but when you do periodic prolonged
fasting you really support
your brain you grow new brain cells
when you run your body on ketones
there's
much less free radical damage there's
much less
waste products being generated as
compared to running your body in glucose
where you have a lot more free radical
damage
and so ketones are more efficient fuel
it's less stress on your body it creates
less waste and more oxygen and less co2
so it's it's good brain food also you're
going to support your immune system
you're going to be able to fight
infections better
you're going to actually increase your
resistance of your cell
from toxins you'll decrease your risk
from cancer because one of the purposes
of your immune system is to
kill cancer cells this is a good benefit
right
and then you have the anti-aging
benefits because your body is recycling
old damaged
tissue and definitely proteins
so you're cleaning up these cells that
are dysfunctional
and you're renewing them so for repair
and regeneration
and anti-aging doing a prolonged fast
here and there is definitely
worth it all right thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help